The Joe Rogan experience.
Shitting yourself is probably the most embarrassing thing a person can do,
right?
Yeah.
You share yourself.
A guy who's known for being handsome and Debonair and a bad ass can't make it to
the toilet and type black.
There's no control over and shoot yourself in your car while you're driving.
You know,
white leather seats.
That's the worst it's going to happen to something happens.
Everybody is going to be a time in your life if you eat risky.
Yeah.
Right?
Think of the most handsome person in the world.
Most beautiful woman in the world splattering all over herself at some point and
her hotness day,
most likely.
Do you remember that?
I don't like thinking about that.
What was the Woody Harrelson movie?
Was it w?
W what does it that was,
he was throwing up.
Was there,
was it
woody Harrelson movie where he played the Bowler?
Oh yeah,
I'll,
I'll a kingpin ting pen.
Yeah.
That was a scene,
right?
There wasn't a shit seat in that.
That was,
I'm thinking of dumb and dumber is a shit.
Seen it.
Well,
he's shitting in the urinal.
That's about it.
Really?
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
I know how to do it.
Is that a fairly brothers movie?
Dumb and dumber eyes.
Big Shit seem too with the Jeff Daniels.
That's right.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's laxative in his,
where he's hanging onto the toilet lid.
Look,
he's going to get shocked to orbit and he's going,
oh yeah.
They got all this weird noises.
Yeah.
Because Jim Carrey was tilt cylinders girl.
Poisoned.
Poisoned his friend.
Yeah,
that's it right there.
There it is full on.
But kingpin would the,
was it a fairly brothers mover?
That's,
um,
that's one of my all time favorite comedy movies.
Pain,
pain.
That's a great guy.
I remember loving it,
but I haven't seen it in so long.
I need to get a look out.
Look that.
And again,
I'm scared to watch movies that I love again and see him in the light of 2019
and go [inaudible] yeah,
this is terrible.
Yeah.
I know that's happened a couple of times happens.
It's weird,
right?
Yeah.
You remembered so fondly.
Look at that.
Bilberry think that hair,
that hair is amazing.
He said was such a good movie,
but like so hair and makeup had to go like,
I'm sure that was his decision.
We're going to make your hair just fan out randomly.
God was,
it's going to look like a spoiler on a Fiero before Donald Trump.
Yeah.
Like a little Trump thing going on there.
It's very similar.
So as a professional bowler now,
the PBA that has a full on orange Afro right now really?
And he's like really good and he's from my hometown.
Yeah.
See if you're a bowl,
you got to do something like that.
Stand out where like purple glittery clothes or some shit.
That's smart.
That's just Brandon.
He's peacock and he's like there is that dude's from Hickory,
North Carolina.
See that's why he wears that shit.
Got Him while he's just got to too.
I mean,
how the fuck else do you get attention when you're a bowler?
So exactly right.
Like that might be the only way to save bowling.
They might have to let go like roller derby and just knock into each other.
What a yeah.
Or board a bowling man.
I've never sat down and watched bowling.
Ari's got a good friend,
Tommy,
what's his name?
He's a professional bowler.
Real Nice Guy.
I met him at a couple of shows.
Okay.
But this guy's a real pro bowler and we were talking about like the financial
opportunities of bowling and this is not good.
Like pro pool player.
The way on both surprised.
It sucks.
It sucks that deck.
Tommy
[inaudible] friend.
I'm sorry.
This heavy boldly.
Recently I bought with my kids.
Yeah.
I five bold.
Dilutes maybe.
I think that's it.
Yeah.
Tommy glutes.
I think that's it.
[inaudible] go with was a,
Yup.
That's him did turn it around 1%.
There's already went to see him bowl.
Yeah.
He's a good guy.
Good guy.
Real fucking killer blower.
Do you,
can you make it curve?
No.
Yeah.
Even try steam roll.
That motherfucker do to ride down the damn metal.
I do it as hard as humanly possible or it's just disturbing for people to watch
and now they have at the,
they have to miles per hour up there so you can see how fast it's like a dam,
you know,
like a pitching thing.
I'm trying to get that bitch fast.
I just want to smash those things.
I get annoyed at the guys who like curve it really good.
Like he goes way over here and it just whips real fast and then a gutter ball.
Oh.
I'm like,
oh that for for fucking both to fucked up.
Look at all that you did.
You have shitty whip watch now watch me ride down the middle.
Struck to me bowling was always like breaking in Pool.
It's like,
yeah,
it's cool to break the balls,
but the real cool thing is to play the game.
Like this is you just breaking the balls over and over again.
It's the same look every time you in,
well it's like bowling,
bowling,
you're just breaking the balls.
That's all you're doing.
Like when you're bowling,
you got pins just knocking down the pins and the exact same order.
It's the same thing every time.
And I know the combinations are different in the way they collide and the where
you impact is different,
but it's still the same thing.
It's a dumb game.
I'm sorry.
And my grandfather was a big bowler man,
bold leagues and he had trophies in his house and Shit.
He used to love bowling,
but I was like a little kid.
I was analyzing bowling cause he'd take me bowling with them.
I was like,
this isn't a nonsense game.
Yeah.
Scams,
nonsense like you to get into it just so you can smoke and drink and is a thing
that they have in the east coast in Boston that they don't even have anywhere
else.
It's called candle pin bowling.
He ever see that shit.
It's which smaller version,
dude?
Dude,
you ball with a softball.
That sounds more fun to me.
But it's huge in the east coast.
Hometown,
Ohio.
They've got a few places actually with gigantic bars that they have all these
lanes for this thing.
Yeah.
For candle pin bowling.
It's called pens or something.
Yeah.
I was looking down on that because I came from grandfather in New Jersey.
I bold regular bowling,
like a fucking American.
Right.
And then I over,
what's this candle pit bull shit.
What'd you guys steal this from?
Finland or something?
What is that nonsense like pins.
Oh mock.
Now see I didn't notice that.
That is ridiculous.
No,
they are shaped that way.
Thrown rocks to thrown rocks at pins.
That's not what I was talking about.
This is really just a bar.
What is that hard?
This is not what you're talking about.
Well,
I mean it is,
but it's,
it's way smaller and it's really just like a bar game.
Oh No,
this I have like five lanes or 10 lands and he could play,
but it's this same game.
Yeah.
Should have been bowling in New England.
They'll have like bowling alleys and you all let's go bowl and they're like,
Oh,
we're candle pin only people like what?
Candle pin only bowling alleys.
Yeah.
So we're going to light these candles.
That's what I want it set them on fire.
It only works on the east coast for some reason.
There's like a few of those things,
like,
how about this?
Hi Lie.
Oh fuck.
People can find out.
Is that logo that fought?
That ball goes fast.
Right?
It's nice.
Actually.
It's way smaller.
And I was thinking in my head,
I'm like,
oh,
no one's different.
Miniature bowling kind of.
Yeah.
Okay.
The ball to keep ball a little bit.
Yeah.
So it's kind of like candle pin bowling,
but the candle pins,
the pins are different.
The shape,
like candles,
that's why it's called candle pin bowling.
If you look at them,
they're thin pins are not,
they're not like fat on the bottom.
That's like what?
Why are we even here?
Yeah.